there was very interesting breaking news
last night that the senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell who of course is
not just a republican but has been one
of the most
pernicious republicans to the causes of
sanity and reason for a long time and
has been very effective at getting
endless numbers of right-wing judges
confirmed successfully obstructed barack
obama's supreme court
nomination of merrick garland back in
2016.
that mitch mcconnell is reportedly
pleased
about donald trump being impeached a
second time
why because he believes it will make it
easier
for the republican party to purge
donald trump to wash its hands of an
association
with donald trump mitch mcconnell has
told associates this has been reported
by the new york times and confirmed by
fox news so take take your pick at this
point
mitch mcconnell has told associates that
he does believe
donald trump committed impeachable
offenses
and that he is pleased that democrats
are going forward with a second
impeachment of the president
he believes it will make it easier to
purge trump from the party and
at the same time representative kevin
mccarthy of california
the minority leader and a big supporter
of donald trump
has reportedly been asking other
republicans
should i call on donald trump to resign
and mccarthy has been personally against
impeachment and he said he and other
party leaders have decided not to lobby
republicans to vote
no and an aide to mccarthy said he's
open to a measure
censuring donald trump in private
mccarthy reached out to a leading house
democrat to see if the chamber would be
willing
to look at a censure vote instead of
impeachment nancy pelosi has since
ruled that out so this is these truly
are unique times in
american political history and when you
take this together
mcconnell is pleased that impeachment is
moving forward
and mccarthy has been calling around
saying what about censure we're not
going to lobby for no votes on
impeachment what are we doing
um this reflects depending on your
perspective
a come to jesus moment for the
republican party
or political posturing and opportunism
now maybe you think i'm
cynical but i think the answer is
obvious
this is political opportunism and in
fact i don't believe that mcconnell is
having a change of heart
on uh on donald trump i believe
mcconnell
has had the same view on trump all along
and he said for as long as i can get
judges through
and block things democrats want to do
we'll sort of stand aside as donald
trump does what he does
here by the way is uh the report i read
you is from
the new york times laura ingram on fox
news also saying they've confirmed
mcconnell
is not going to stand in the way of
impeachment and is quote done with
donald trump further fox news has
confirmed that while he's not said
whether he supports conviction in the
senate
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
uh is not going to stand in the way
of this impeachment effort instead to be
done with trump
now given all that and that ultimately
is the key
does mitch mcconnell support conviction
of donald trump on impeachment will he
vote to convict
when the senate takes up this second
impeachment of donald trump with just
minutes ago as we've been recording here
was walked over
by the house impeachment managers to the
united states
senate i don't know the answer to that
my instinct is probably not at the same
time mitch mcconnell's wife elaine chao
was one of the first to resign in last
week's
run of resignations she was donald
trump's transportation
secretary i believe that this is nothing
other than mitch mcconnell
doing what he likely planned to do for a
long time mitch mcconnell has probably
hated trump for a
while but like most republicans he was
either afraid of trump's cult
or calculating that it didn't make sense
to come out against trump to the extent
that he could keep
getting judges confirmed and get tax
reform done and on
and on and on and so i don't think
mcconnell
deserves any any any praise for this
um what he wants is for nancy pelosi's
name
and democrats to be attached in public
to this impeachment and he wants to hide
and figure out how he can use this to
his advantage to get this mess cleaned
up the mess being
the destruction that donald trump has
brought to the republican party
so there is no praise here for mitch
mcconnell
complicity due to being afraid is still
complicity
complicity or indifference due to
political opportunism
or self-aggrandizement or personal
benefit it's all
just as bad mitch mcconnell got his
judges
and now he wants to get rid of his old
baggage and
it may work unfortunately there is a
very short political memory in the
united states
we've already forgotten about things
that happened six months ago that
appeared to be really big deals at this
point and so the big narratives are what
matter
and the big narrative mitch mcconnell
wants is uh
i didn't stand in the way of impeachment
i
i used that second impeachment to try to
wash our hands of trump
i got my judges done we got our supreme
court justices and now let's get rid of
the baggage
none of them deserve to have their
reputations rehabilitated i've said that
a lot
and that is all that this ultimately is
and
where i get to in the end is what i
mentioned before will mitch mcconnell
vote to convict
in the impeachment trial of donald trump
in the senate i don't know the answer
maybe tomorrow i'll have some stronger
feelings about it
start your day and your new year off
right with just egg which is one of our
sponsors you've heard me talk about the
importance of having a diet that is
more heavily plant-based than it's
something i've done
over the last few years i've always
loved eggs
so it's great that there is a delicious
plant-based
version of egg with all the protein of
egg that just egg brings with it but
it's made from
mung beans so it uses 98 percent less
water
and causes 93 fewer carbon emissions
than a conventional egg
and just egg cooks and tastes exactly
like
a conventional egg i've tried it for
omelets
scrambled eggs french toast banana bread
pad thai anything you'd normally use
eggs for and i actually think if i
cooked something for a friend without
telling them
about just egg they wouldn't even know
the difference
find it in the egg aisle at your grocery
store
on amazon prime now or on instacart
and they also have a frozen version
perfect for breakfast sandwiches
just egg try it out